the death toll from the pandemic
continues to soar across Europe where
Italy faces the biggest challenge our
Elizabeth Palmer reports from London for
Italian doctors and nurses this has
become a marathon of effort and
determination the lockdown is strict big
cities have never looked so empty and
yet more people are dying of coronavirus
in Italy than anywhere else on earth but
there is a game of good news the rate of
infection is definitely slowing and the
number of deaths over the weekend
dropped quite sharply Spain has the
second largest outbreak in Europe the
government is extending the state of
emergency for two more weeks here in
Britain though people can go out and
about freely the Prime Minister had a
warning don't think that fresh air in
itself automatically provides some
immunity you have to stay two metres
apart in most countries but China the
corona virus is still spreading but in
wuhan where this all began restrictions
are starting to be lifted and life is
slowly returning to normal there have
been no new cases for the fourth day
running for CBS this morning
I'm Elizabeth Palmer in London normal we
all look forward to that seems like it's
a long way off though